et toujours concernant les états unis
démocrates et républicains font pression
sur joe biden pour agir contre la russie
des sénateurs des deux camps réclame au
président américain d'expulser jusqu'à
300 diplomate russe si moscou n'accepte
pas d'accorder davantage de visas pour
le personnel de l'ambassade américaine
une démarche condamnés par les autorités
russes les explications avec notre
correspondant à washington thomas bonnin
voici un nouvel exemple que la posture
agressive des etats-unis à l'encontre de
la russie peut parfois faire oublier les
divergences politiques entre le parti
démocrate et le parti républicain il ya
donc cet exemple avec une lettre qui a
été cosignée à la fois par des sénateurs
démocrates mais aussi donc par celle des
sénateurs républicains tous font partie
des commissions sénatoriales soit des
affaires étrangères soit du
renseignement et les adressent une
lettre à destination de joe biden lettre
dans laquelle il dénonce distille la
disproportion de la représentation
diplomatique entre les etats-unis et la
russie il estime par exemple que
l'ambassade américaine à moscou doit
pouvoir accueillir plus de diplomates
américains et que si jamais moscou
venait à refuser et bien alors joe biden
devrait procéder à l'expulsion veut pas
moins de 300 diplomate russe écoutez la
disproportion dans la représentation
diplomatique est inacceptable la russie
doit délivrer à ses de visas pour
s'approcher d'une parité entre le nombre
de diplomates américains travaillant en
russie et le nombre de diplomates russes
travaillant aux états unis si une telle
action n'est pas prise nous vous
pressons de commencer a expulsé des
diplomates russes pour parvenir à cette
parité nous croyons qu'une telle étape
serait raisonnable est réciproque
alors ce chiffre de 300 diplomate russe
n'est pas véritablement ce qu'on peut
appeler raisonnable puisqu'il s'agirait
d'une procédure sans précédent dans
l'histoire américaine et puis surtout ce
chiffre est assez étonnant parce que
l'ambassade russe aux états unis emploie
en réalité moins de 300 ans diplomate en
son sein écoutez la réaction justement
des autorités russes
ceux qui proposent de telles mesures
cherche apparemment à fermer les bureaux
américains en russie ils doivent se
rendre compte que dans ce cas ils seront
responsables de cette situation ou bien
par un manque de connaissances en
matière de relations internationales
les sénateurs ont tout simplement pris
en compte et diplomates russes qui
travaillent dans la mission permanente
auprès de l'onu alors cette demande
formulée par ces sénateurs américains
est pour le moment resté sans réponse de
la part de la maison blanche on sait que
la question des ambassades est un sujet
sensible entre moscou et washington
puisqu'il faut rappeler que les deux
ambassadeurs russes aux états unis et
américains en russie avaient quitté
leurs ambassades respectives pendant
quelque temps avant finalement d'y
retourner c'était seulement au mois de
juin dernier quelques jours après la
rencontre à genève entre le job d'un et
vladimir poutine